and chest economies he was grand master
Hikaru Nakamura on his first trip to
Africa we are in Zhu Baird Park in
downtown Johannesburg you played chess
growing up in the park in Washington
Square but how did this experience
compare I found this experience very
enjoyable I mean I think it's it's a
little bit different than New York and
that people here have a lot more passion
and and I really just I enjoyed the
whole experience because when you play
against all these guys and they're
they're trash-talking there are they're
really getting into it I felt there's a
different level of passion for trust
here than then I felt when I played in
in New York City yeah for those of you
looking to check out the videos on our
YouTube channel this was like Feingold
vs. Simon Williams to a whole new level
was the level of trash-talking
distracting in any way I know not at all
I actually I enjoyed it I mean just live
it's part of the whole experience and
really I mean I think that's what makes
it fun to play in the parks I mean
obviously as a professional chess player
you still used to playing in a
professional professional events where
it's very quiet you don't talk very much
and I think playing in the park it
harkens back to like a different time in
my life when when I was just just coming
up and starting and so it's just it's
it's great and that's how it should be
when you're playing the park in a
non-serious environment so it's just the
video recording is what I Square is got
down there dignity
[Applause]
and you were giving three one-time odds
and ten to one money odds how did it end
up working out are you gonna be buying
beers tonight with some winnings I think
I ended up losing money but not much
because I lost one game to this this guy
very early on and then I won pretty much
every game but but still I think more
more importantly since we weren't
playing for serious money is that it was
good to see the talent level because I
think when you think about Africa there
are not a lot of strong players there
handful of GM's a couple of AIIMS as
well and so to see these players some
fumar about like twenty one twenty two
hundred and the way they play it I mean
I think there's a lot of raw raw talent
potentially and I think if you know in
the future there is a chance hopefully
in Africa that there will be some some
really strong chess players so I think
really for a place like South Africa and
Africa is a continent in general I mean
the the future and the possibilities are
unlimited I think cuz they certainly
haven't reached anywhere near the top so
I think down the line is you know
hopefully you'll you'll see just keep on
developing and on this continent and
you're the last minute invited guests of
the South African Junior Chess
Championships what is your role with the
tournament
um well it's pretty random I when I was
in London the last night of the classic
I went out to dinner with a couple of
friends and there's this one French guy
who I know quite well and he mentioned
he's always been coming down to Cape
Town so so basically I just cited more
or less on a whim to come down to South
Africa and from talking with Graham
Jorgenson who's the technical advisor
for the Grantchester or I found at this
event was going on I think well
originally it's just going to be a
purification having the opportunity to
come to an event like this try to
inspire the kids try to make them
understand the chess is something that
you can do professionally something that
it's not just simply a game I mean I
think really that's that's all you can
do is try to inspire kids and especially
in Africa where I think the
opportunities are much more limited I
think anything that top player like
myself can do to try and try and help
them out or try and try and inspire them
is really what it's all about right
2,500 kids get to meet a top 10 player
probably for the first time let's go
back to the park you played a giant
bullet chess match something that Danny
wrench and Maxine vie Sheila Groff have
gotten into the last couple of years at
the same field Cup do you want to
reprise this match with Danny or Maxime
at the next thing field Cup I mean I've
seen the videos of them playing perhaps
I mean I think it's it's I think one
game is fine more than one game it
starts to become a little bit insane but
yeah I mean I wouldn't be opposed to
trying it out so so maybe one of these
times when we're all in Santa Lewis
again
and finally after you leave Johannesburg
where do the rest of your travels going
to be like in South Africa um well after
Johannesburg I'm gonna head up to Kruger
National Park try and see some some
wildlife and some game animals out there
and I'll be there for a couple of days
then I'll go down to Cape Town
check out Table Mountain Robben Island
obviously which was very famous and
maybe head off to the stellenbosch
region to try out some wine so just just
trying to enjoy the vacation before I
get back in the chest so it's just been
it's been great so far and hopefully it
will keep on enjoying the vacation I
need some more biltong I'm guessing yeah
I mean I think any time you come to a
country that's different certainly
should try out the local specialities
obviously I mean for me I eat meat so
it's not a problem I'm like yourself for
example but still nevertheless eh I
think when you come to a country really
sure to try out the local food and so
far I've tried out that I had a kudu
steak last night it's another animal
so yeah I've just enjoyed everything
about it so far and it's great to see
see what's going on here because I think
when you when you look at the news a lot
of times Africa is portrayed in a rather
negative light so I think it's it's
great to be here and to see it with my
own eyes and to see the things things
are actually quite nice here in South
Africa fantastical it was quite a time
seeing you play bliss with the raucous
crowd and for those of you wanting to
see some of those blitz games and the
giant bullet blitz game in downtown
Johannesburg check out the chess comm
YouTube page